thanks very much Robbie thank you it is
it is an honor to be here this afternoon
I'm gonna start by just setting
expectations because it took me a while
just to find this place and just you
understand I'm an art history major
speaking in front of a bunch of
engineering students in an engineering
area so rather intimidating it's much
easier for me to be in front of other
audiences so we're gonna give this a
shot I was asked to come in and give you
a little bit of background on myself a
bit of the strobus story some more
stories some lessons along the way and
in particular as the title slide shows
here you know this idea of an inch wide
mile deep I want to take sort of one
lesson that we've learned actually both
from the kana days as well as a Strava
days see if I can go a little deeper on
that a strategy that work really well
for us as a go-to-market may not work
for everybody but in our case it's been
pivotable twice through two different
startups so well it's just growing and
by the way my hope is 2025 minutes of me
talking and then we can get some Q&A
some quick background so as I mentioned
art history major actually grew up in
Reno Nevada I was lucky enough to go out
to Harvard studied art history learn
very quickly that it's really cold back
there so I hooked it back as quick as I
could to the west coast I graduate in
1990 the previous century I came out
here and I went to work for a venture
firm a firm called ta associates in
downtown Palo Alto a great job out of
school this is pre-internet folks so my
job was to basically sit on the phone
all day long and talk to entrepreneurs
call startups try to find out whether
there was an investment opportunity
great for two reasons one I learned the
business of you know the language of
business but two I caught the bug to be
an entrepreneur and so in late 1995
I left that firm and with a good friend
of mine actually someone who was a
professor here at Stanford the Economics
Department a guy named Michael Horvath
we found in what became Conner
communications con a perfect example of
going an inch wide and a mile deep
alright and what I'm talking about there
is picking a niche something that too
many people may look like too small an
opportunity but going really deep into
that opportunity trying to be authentic
they're trying to develop leadership in
that space with the hopes that then that
opportunity leads to something bigger in
the case of Cano
we did was we found this opportunity and
customer email and this is 1995
companies are just beginning to go
online beginning to build their internet
presence and they have this problem
which is as soon as they go online they
start getting customer email and there
weren't systems to actually answer those
messages
so we developed a company and with some
folks other than me who wrote the
software we were able to come up with a
solution five years later we started two
guys in a dog in 1995 by 2000 we were
global company 53 offices around the
world 1200 employees generating hundreds
of millions in revenue traded on NASDAQ
sort of your classic we got very lucky
right place right time but we picked
that inch-wide mile-deep
I can tell you when we were trying to
raise capital we were accused of being a
feature not a product not even a I mean
definitely not a company but what we
proved was by going deep into that one
space that customer email space it gave
us that credibility that then allowed us
to expand in our customer base and
ultimately offer a whole bunch of other
things to our existing customers and
then we get to strata so I left Cana in
2000 to start a family sit on some
boards do some things that probably I
shouldn't have a horrible bicycle
accidents and way too much time in
Stanford Medical Center but ultimately
caught the bug to be an entrepreneur
again and Michael and I came together in
2009 to launch Strava quick background
on Strava
so 2009 January of 2009 that's the
official start date to be clear its
history goes all the way back again to
the previous century as I mentioned
Michael and I've been friends for a long
time we met in The Boathouse right there
that's Newell boathouse on the Cambridge
and the Charles River there in Cambridge
at Harvard we met there on the crew team
it was an amazing experience really hard
to define for those of you who haven't
ever been in a boat like that but the
camaraderie the esprit de corps frankly
just the trash-talking and the
competition everything that comes with
being on that team was perfect it was
sort of what defined my college
experience the only problem was that I
graduated and when I graduated poof it
disappeared this whole idea of sort of
having my tribe my team that I could
hang out with and that kept me inspired
was gone and so as early as 99
five Michael and I had actually
developed a business plan it's called
Cana sports at the time not Strava but
we were fully intent on creating this
virtual locker room we were going to use
this new thing called the Internet to
create this place where we could get all
of our buddies to bring their workouts
together we were going to have this
wonderful sort of virtual team
good-news-bad-news in 1995 right the bad
news we were way too early were about 15
years too early in terms of the idea the
technology was not there to capture the
activities and frankly even the consumer
behavior wasn't there but the good news
was by pursuing kind of sports that's
what actually introduced us to the
customer email problem so lesson number
one that I would just share with you you
know oftentimes I talked to
entrepreneurs and they'll say to me I
just or I should say we wanna be on a
burners they want to go start something
but they just say to me I just don't
know the right idea I just don't have
the right idea I would just caution you
that pick an idea and just start rolling
with it start having conversations and
you'll be amazed at where it takes you
if anybody had told me that a virtual
locker room would lead to an enterprise
software company worth 11 billion
dollars I would have laughed but that is
what happened like the opportunity of
pursuing the sports introduced us to
this problem because of the sporting
good companies and the things that they
were experiencing online and because we
were objective we were able to evolve
our business and become kana
communications right the other piece of
good news was we were 15 years too early
but we were still very passionate about
the idea and so come 2009 the world had
changed for one things like wearable
devices the smartphone's you're able to
capture activities in ways you couldn't
do it 10 years earlier and the other
thing that had changed was consumers
themselves the athletes it was you're
much more comfortable sharing your
information online that was not
something we were doing in the late
1990s so 2009 we decide to start a
business how do we go about doing it
right we had this vision Michael and I
were really excited about creating a
consumer brand it was not something
we've done before we done enterprise
software but when we thought about the
companies that we admired they were much
more akin to that the virgin's and a
Patagonia is in the north faces of the
world these these iconic brands and so
that's what we wanted to do with Strava
and we thought how could we create
something using the internet to inspire
this global community of athletes so
that was the viz
for the business from day one we still
have that in the business plan but our
go-to-market strategy was this niche it
was basically taking a page right out of
the Khanna playbook let's pick one
category one group of athletes go really
deep be authentic with them and let's
see where that lends us or sort of takes
us down the road in this particular case
we picked the passionate cyclist in fact
internally we refer to them as mammals
these are middle-aged men in lycra all
right that is our target audience all
right and on the surface to us they look
really really good very fanatical about
their sport right very intense and
obsessed with their data and the
technology associated with cycling they
tend to spend a lot on their sport and
frankly there wasn't another solution
out there in the market there were lots
of things coming out for runners and so
forth but there was nothing for the
cycling audience so Michael and I looked
at that and said great this is perfect
but again I will tell you when we talked
to investors even family and friends we
were accused time and again of cute
little hobby but you're never going to
be able to build a business there we
heard this over and over and over
despite hearing it because of the effect
that we had at Cana and frankly we were
sort of middle-aged men in lycra and we
needed this solution so we just started
building and we did four things that I
want to share with you when it comes to
being an inch wide and a mile deep first
thing we did was we did grassroots
recruiting right oftentimes in
entrepreneurs particularly here in a
valley you're immediately trying to
figure out how do you get your first
thousand your first 10,000 your first
hundred thousand customers online we did
not think that way we were literally I
can remember the first five cyclists
that we had on stralla right there's a
gentleman I won't give you his name but
his initials or DB he's our first
customer he's still on Strava eleven
years later like we were begging and
borrowing and stealing from cyclists
anywhere we could we would go to local
cycling clubs here we would raise e
stories of going down to Costco and
trying to figure out how to negotiate
with Costco to buy tens of thousands of
dollars worth of Garmin cycling
computers just so we could give those
away to our friends so that they would
participate on Strava because we could
not get garment to sell us a device so
we had to negotiate with Costco we
got fleeced by eBay sellers who promised
us hundreds of Garmin's devices that
would never show up after us sending
them checks I mean we did everything
wrong but we were worried doing is
really going grassroots trying to find
those early customers early cyclists
that we could do which was the second
thing create a conversation with them
right this was about sitting down and
really listening to what their needs
were as a cyclist forging this
relationship we didn't call them
customers they were our partners in this
project and what was happening was when
you had that conversation you start to
hear these little nuances that become
very very important for instance as a
cyclist it doesn't matter whether you're
going on a five mile ride a 20 mile ride
a 50 mile ride or a hunter mile ride it
turns out that there's always this
iconic moment there's this moment when
you hit hill and you're gonna climb it
as hard as you can and that's the thing
that cyclists remember it's like what
they memorialize on their rides is the
the climb that they do so for us that
was important because if we could figure
out how to capture memorialize that
climb inside Strava that's the kind of
unique opportunity that nobody else was
offering we learned that they were
really fascinated with power or wattage
you know sort of the the energy output
that they were doing so how could we
take advantage of that data that was
coming through things like the watches
and their bicycle and take advantage of
that information and do something unique
online all right the third thing we did
that was really critical at Strava was
we focused on this notion of engagement
but again if you think about a consumer
model you have acquisition of your
customer you have engagement of your
customer you have monetization that's
kind of the three basics right there's
churn and retention everything else but
the three basics are acquire your
customer engaged them and then monetize
that Strava it was all about engagement
that's where we obsessed we spent our
time trying to figure out once we'd
found one of those cyclists grass roots
or otherwise how do we get them to just
keep uploading time and again how do we
make the experience as exciting as
possible how do we create this long-term
relationship with them all right
their thought process was twofold one
was because we were talking about a
vertical niche we knew that we had a
finite number of customers out there so
any one that we got we wanted to keep
around but the other reason that that
was so important was that we learned
very early our best source of growth was
word of mouth so by focusing on
engagement we actually saw that our
growth actually accelerated so without
focusing on it that was a great strategy
and then the fourth thing that I'll
mention that was really part of this
inch-wide mile-deep strategy was a
simple notion of what we call single
player mode all right there's this
misconception with Strava that from day
one we were out to sort of build the
community how do we sort of bring this
party together in one big place and yes
we were really excited about this idea
of a virtual team like we believe that
people make other people active it's
something we've seen we can actually
show you the data it's really true as
soon as you have followers on Strava
really good things happen but in the
early days of Strava it was all about
what we called single-player mode and
what I mean by that is we had to assume
we had one customer one cyclist who was
uploading one ride on Strava how do we
make that experience valuable so that
want to come back again right so it was
all about high utility sort of just high
value from that one experience it was
that single player mode that was
critical early on I talked to way too
many entrepreneurs where they're like
it's going to be this amazing community
based business but we're just we can't
figure how to bring everybody together
like you got to get product market fit
for that one customer and once you do
that a couple years in we got very
excited about the community features but
we had to grow into that we had to
mature into that opportunity so those
were the four the last one I'll say that
we did was what I would call patience
right expansion only happened after we
really felt that we had nailed this
niche this first group all right and
what I meant by that was we needed to
know that we were the definitive leaders
when it came to serving the cyclists
online right we could see that both in
the numbers we could see that an
engagement we could see it by what was
being written in the press but it wasn't
until we felt that we had established
that number one position in the
marketplace that we gained the
confidence to really think about now an
expansion strategy and we frankly we
took a page I would argue more so out of
some of the other sporting good
companies than we did sort of tech
companies because the expansion for us
was akin to what Nike did or others
where we picked a new sport there was a
new vertical and said okay now it's time
and we went after running it was three
years later 2012 that we launched
running we launched it first off as a
separate app today it's all integrated
into one but we actually had cycling
Strava cycling Strava run they were
separate we learned a ton of difficult
lessons we originally thought we could
basically take the cycling experience
reskin it is the old 80/20 rule 80% of
it would work for runners no if we were
going to be authentic if we were going
to get that same kind of high running
engagement we really had to start
internally with the DNA of the company
and rebuild from the ground up a running
experience but it did work what we saw
as I mentioned earlier word-of-mouth
began to spread we saw a really
fascinating viral effect we saw that
many of our athletes are not cyclists or
runners we find that they tend to be
multi-sport
unless you're professional and you're
making a living as a cyclist you're not
riding every day you're riding and then
you're running and you're skiing and the
in the winter and you're swimming and
you're playing around you're doing lots
of different things and so we found our
existing athletes we're expanding with
us and they were bringing more and more
of their friends along see fast flow
today as was already mentioned you know
we've had some fun here in the last few
years we've just include 50 million
athletes we had about a million athletes
now every month we've truly gone global
because it says it there you know we're
now over 195 countries there is not a
country in the world where you can't
find a Strava upload you can literally
find guys doing fat bike rides to the
South Pole on the Strava
you can find folks that are going to the
gym climbing to the top of Everest the
vast majority of our members are outside
the United States 82% probably but it's
more exciting than the just the
geographic expansion is the the
diversity of our community as I
mentioned you can find Alpine climbers
you can find professional cyclist you
can find Olympic gold medalist on Strava
but you can also find people who are
trying to do their very first 5k or
they're doing a first charity walk to
raise money for breast cancer or
whatever it is it's a really fascinating
mix really what it's become is it's the
home for their athletic life this is the
place hopefully for those of you raise
your hand they're using it we're really
hoping that you find that this is the
place you can post your ride you can
post your workouts and really share you
know similar interests and and common
goals with the rest of the community
that's out there the other point that I
want to make here we continue to be
obsessed with engagement it says up here
we measure success by how many athletes
sweat
that's absolutely
right now instead of just running and
cycling there's literally 34 different
sports you can do on Strava you can do
everything from hiking and walking on a
Sunday afternoon to posting kite
boarding and Nordic skiing you name it
it's available on Strava we see roughly
15 to 20 million activities per week
funny stat it took us eight years to see
our first billion activities on Strava
it took us 18 months to see our second
billion took us 13 months to see our
third billion and just again if you
build patience into these models really
interesting things start to happen but
you have to have that authenticity in
place and the last stat here on Strava
then I'll get into some of the more
interesting challenges of the business
this fifty to one ratio this probably
one we're most proud of what this stands
for is for every one minute that
somebody is inside the Strava app
they're spending an average of 50
minutes working out and we're actually
seeing that stat continue to increase so
again our mission is to make sure that
you're out there you're being active we
don't need your eyeballs in the app all
the time we just want to know that we're
a part of that experience and so that's
that's been the mission force trama and
as we go forward it's largely a lot of
the same
it's a freemium business model right you
can use the vast majority of Strava for
free and then there's these upgrade
paths where people can subscribe and
that's that's been a business so I make
it sound like niche you focus on it you
go global bada-bing bada-boom
right it's all easy trust me I could
spend the next three hours walking you
through the vast majority of challenges
and heartaches that we've been through
it's been a crazy time lots of ups and
downs through Strava I pulled up four
here that are related to this idea of
just the challenges associated with
going an inch wide a mile deep but I
could list another twenty the four that
I've got here is this notion of
abandoning the core right so great to go
up to the niche but the minute you think
about expansion you've got a core group
of audience that's saying hey wait a
second what about me right as soon as we
went after running we had this horrible
sort of PR fiasco around the cyclist
feeling like they'd been abandoned right
so how to sort of think about what that
balance looks like what it is to
continue to serve the core needs of you
that audience that's got you to that
successful point yet knowing that you're
looking for expansion so we really sort
of muddled our way through that
I call something up there the noise of
opportunity it's just a simple challenge
even within cycling you know if you
think about where we started we started
what we call sort of post ride and what
I mean by that is Strava was really
great when somebody had gone out done a
ride and then they put their information
on a Strava and we showed them something
interesting we hopefully sort of
surprised and delighted them but it
turns out that there's all these great
opportunities to help cyclists while
they're riding or before they go ride
how do we help them discover new
activities it turns out that there's
just so many different ways in which we
can expand our business and the services
we offer that it becomes deafening the
noise of opportunity and so we've really
had to refine the art inside Strava
around prioritization what are the
things we're not going to do I often
referred to it as the no list just the
things that are on the no list that
despite a lot of people wanting us to do
them we're not going to do that at least
not right now third challenge that I
would mention to you the business model
evolution right again here in this value
here all the time you know things like
multi-level revenue models and and so
forth and these are referring to this
idea that you get these consumer models
so you often sort of see these multiple
ways in which you can generate revenue
and trust me over 10 years Strava has
experimented across the board
we've got our subscription business
we've done e-commerce with our athletes
we've had marketing and advertising
associated with Strava we've had data
insights we've we've been pulled into
lots of different things imagine once
you have 50 million athletes it's a
pretty rich target audience for a lot of
other brands and businesses but there's
some really interesting sort of
strategic and ethical questions that
come around that and so as much as we've
evolved the business and tried different
things I will tell you we always come
back to our core in some ways business
model evolution for us follows that same
strategy of inch-wide mile deep we're at
our best when we know our customer is
the athlete and that's the business
we're going to be great at and that's
the subscription business and the last
one I put up there Silicon Valley GBF
trend so what I'm referring to there is
they get big fast mentality that seems
to be pervasive in Silicon Valley if
you're not getting big fast if you're
not growing as fast you possibly can
somehow you're failing all right we've
felt that pressure internally this isn't
just from investors you know the
employees themselves to know that we're
sort of a
succeeding at the rate we want to know
that we're fulfilling our potential but
I would just caution you that you know
this notion of get big fast things that
tend to go up like this have a funny way
of moving just as fast the other way and
so Michael and I have sort of taken this
philosophy that if we've got to kind of
go up into the right this way we finally
end up in a much healthier stronger
platform so we're willing to be patient
and sort of build that into the model
but we know that it comes with a lot of
grief and a lot of interesting
discussions at the boardroom and in
other places so those are just some
simple examples again I could go on
recruiting and retention inside Strava
we could probably spend an hour in here
around privacy and what it is to sort of
hold people's geo locations inside
Strava and if any of you have seen I
mean there have been fascinating stories
published on Strava around the heatmap
and we've had senate enquiries and we've
had nato that's been in touch with us i
mean you name it we've had sort of
fascinating things that have happened
but fundamentally they come back to
these really basic issues that you just
need to be aware of
all right then lastly here let me just
give you five quick takeaways that again
relate to this idea of inch wide mile
deep that I've learned along the way and
we'll see if these resonate with you
first one takeaway number one don't
confuse go-to-market with vision okay
vision vision is the long term dream
right it's the holy grail it's the brass
ring it's that thing that as a company
you should be aspiring to get to but you
never quite get there all right go in a
market that's a strategy that's it that
is a waypoint along the journey to get
to the vision right at Strava from day
one we can show you the business plan
our vision was this idea of what would
it be like to bring this global
community of athletes together because
we believe that that's what inspires you
to keep going is the people who keep
people active but I go to market was
let's go deep with this niche in cycling
all right I've seen way too many
entrepreneurs they do one of two
problems number one they immediately
think that their vision has got to be
their go-to market
they try to basically be everything to
everybody or I see the opposite problem
I often see entrepreneurs who take their
initial product idea and they think
that's the company remember as
entrepreneurs you're in the business of
building a company not a product the
product is a means to the end
again don't confuse these two they're
really important and you need them both
you need them but you need them both for
the company you need them for investors
you need them for employees this is what
inspires everybody takeaway number two
to quote Homer if you serve too many
masters you'll soon suffer okay we've
seen this time and again it's drama this
is one that's been painful now I'm not
talking about sort of the expansion of
the athletes you know yes we have a very
diverse population that's on Strava
today with lots of different needs
trust me trying to take care of the
needs of a trail runner in Brazil is
fundamentally different from that roadie
who lives in the Netherlands
it's just they are different that's ok
they're all athletes there's sort of
Universal bonds that bring those
together what I'm referring to here is
what happens a little bit what I talked
about a second ago with this business
model evolution right when you have
customers that start to emerge that are
not the athletes in our case like when
brands started coming to us and really
saying how can we participate in Strava
we'll pay you to be involved in Strava
how can we advertise to your athletes
things like that where we have other
companies fascinating here's a great one
we have a product called Strava Metro
where we're actually working with city
planners and local governments around
the world we have about 300 partners
today where they're looking at the data
that we're able to pull up for these
cities to understand the way in which
people move through the city cyclists
pedestrians runners and so forth so that
they can make more informed decisions
about the way in which they build their
their bicycle paths infrastructure and
their pedestrian infrastructure really
good stuff I mean this is this is
fashioning stuff the problem is if these
guys become your customers and you're
trying to meet the needs of Transport
for London or you know the state of
Oregon while you're simultaneously
trying to take care of the athletes
there's a lot of conflict that's built
into that so it's drama we've had to
take some hard hard look inside and
basically make you know plant a stake in
the ground our customer is the athlete
that is who we're there to take care of
and anybody else that we work with they
are our partners so as long as we know
that together we're doing something for
the athlete great but we know that the
fundamental business the revenue
everything else needs to come from the
athlete it's worked well for us take
away 3 remember the Starbucks test
okay so quick anecdote going back about
ten years ago start a Strava I was
sitting in a local Starbucks here in
Menlo Park with a good friend of mine
it's a consultant she's written a number
of books around subscriptions and
membership economies and so forth and I
was wanting to pick her brain on a lot
of things and she turned to me and she
said mark tell me a little bit about
your target audience
tell me about sort of this addressable
market just going after and I looked up
and in the Starbucks in a far corner was
frankly a group of mammals bunch of guys
sitting around and they're like oh
they're called the cycling kit right and
they were having their lattes after
their ride and I pointed over to them to
Robbie and I said right there if you
look at those six guys that's our target
audience and Robbie's eyes lit up she's
like oh my gosh you don't know how many
entrepreneurs when I'm sitting here in
Starbucks and I asked that question they
tend to go like this they say well
anybody anybody inside the Starbucks
they're a perfect target for sort of
what we want to go do and she and I had
this long conversation unaffected well
that sounds great in theory that you've
got a big enough opportunity that
everybody should be a customer when
you're an early-stage startup it is
really hard to get product market fit
for that diverse group so again I'm kind
of repeating over over but the Starbucks
test is a good one for any of you to go
out to I will challenge you to login to
the Starbucks it's a really diverse
population that's sitting inside of
Starbucks anytime day or night but try
to figure out who that target audience
is that you're you're initially going
after your go-to-market takeaway number
four even being a niche number one gives
you street cred right do not
underestimate the power of being number
one even when it's a niche and there's
really three reasons all right the first
one is just credibility right even if
it's just a niche if you're number one
if you're the leader net space I'm
telling you you develop thought
leadership you develop a voice in the
market people will want to talk to you
you will see that the partners start to
emerge we've seen this now twice in both
of our companies it works really well do
not underestimate that credibility the
second thing it does is frankly it just
develops confidence right you're winning
if you're number one you're winning
you're beating somebody out there and
with confidence comes as courage to now
begin to think about expansion all right
and the third and at least is this
happened now twice for us do not honor
estimate what happens with these niches
in the case of Kanna what was this
little thing called customer email
turned out to be a massive problem for
every single company on the planet that
wanted to go online so when initially we
were accused of going after a feature it
turned into a beautiful high-value
business and in Strava we had to laugh
we never would have guessed that in the
last 10 years we'd see the Renaissance
we've seen in cycling there's been this
explosion in participation in cycling
that we could never have projected but
the reality is were still growing in
that space even 10 years later it's
become like the golf of the 21st century
so in both cases what were these little
niches by going deep and frankly some
luck that was involved but the knits
themselves ended up proving to be more
valuable than we had initially
anticipated the last takeaway please
please focus on great rather than big ok
I can't say this strongly enough the too
much time if we spend time think about
how to get big it's again like I said
big really quick come down really fast
focusing on this notion of being great
focusing on this notion of being
authentic focusing on being the best at
something that provides that platform
from which expansion comes right it's
it's not rocket science but I think we
just lose sight of this in this in this
sense of sort of how to move as fast as
we possibly can this the speed at which
we need to move so again I just always
come back to great versus big and the
irony here is if your great big will
come it will come don't I'll finish here
just the three confidence in the niche
please yeah I know every single time you
look at in the surface you will have a
naysayers have comments in it it has
worked at least for us - for - I'm
willing to bet on the third time second
real problems for real people okay when
you've got a niche you've identified
that that real customer again think
about kana we found a real problem we
found this customer emo we found the
people who were dealing with it they
were the people who were running
customer service inside these companies
and they had real budget in a case of
Strava because we focus on this we found
that cycle so you found that person we
understood their needs and we could
build product that was a five
so real people real problems just do
that it's amazing what happens when you
find the real people real problem even
if you're a one-person startup that
person who has the problem or the
opportunity they will listen to you they
will take the call and the third I just
mentioned just commit to being great
right it's it's just it's it's a it
being great it leads to wins rights wins
leads to confidence and confidence
really leads to that expansion
opportunity alright enough of my talking
hopefully that makes sense
great then thank you for letting me
share a couple notes and let's open it
up to questions anybody now you're
serving people and I imagine most of
those people don't fall into your
initial image that you designed for it
so how did the design of your change
great question so question basically was
as we expanded from this niche to this
large global population what were the
strategy that we deployed to really
begin to not only grow aggressively but
meet the needs of this diverse audience
I get that so I think there's a couple
things that I would point to that
happened some of the things that frankly
were outside of our control but proved
to be really valuable when we launched
we were a web only business the
smartphones while they were out in the
marketplace they were not capable of
handling this sort of activity data and
so forth the battery life was bad GPS
was bad so we were web-based which is
part of where that slow growth came from
and once we were able to go mobile in
2011 even just with our niche we saw
expansion happen the app stores and
everything else just loud for a level
expansion second thing that happened was
we focused very much we realized that
our community was driving us out
internationally without we couldn't
control it there wasn't like we chose to
go to the UK or to Brazil which are two
of our largest countries after the u.s.
our athletes immediately took us there
and so by focusing on how to become a
really strong international company
localization but also understanding the
nuances that were taking place as I
joked earlier about like the trail
runner in Brazil like we actually now
have people in country in these places
who really help us understand the
nuances associated with the culture
around sport Brazilians are fascinating
there's a combination of two things that
are going on there's this love for sport
down there but there's also this love
for social media and so understanding
the way in which they want to interact
with drama became really important and
then I think the third thing was as I
mentioned we had this single-player mode
for really the first few years which
allowed us to get that product market
fit but there came a time when we began
to see that the the community features
we could build in Ostrava were really
really important and just simple little
examples one would be very authentic
something as simple as a leaderboard so
you can go onto Strava you can post your
ride one of the things that you will see
pop up is that you have ridden on a
stretch of road or run on a trail where
other people have have been on and will
show you how you rank on that on that
trail now everybody says they're not
competitive but everybody loves to look
at that and we let you slice it and dice
it lots of different ways so there's
sort of a community element or context
to the experience that ended up being
really good because now you're inviting
your friends to join Strava
which is a third thing that we did we
realized that our best source of growth
was word of mouth but we figured out
there are ways we can make that really
easy so simple things like when you
finish a ride hey add your friends to
that ride that may not have been on
stralla
there were tricks like that that we
started to build into the into the
experience yeah a long time let's travel
user
- but I am a preview sir and so my
question is in terms of monetization
because it seems like I don't let people
castrato I actually don't know anybody
who pays for summat and so the question
is what do you do about that and maybe
maybe my sample size is too small and
you guys are doing a great job I'm just
wondering it seems like and if some
options would be you you know you can
use raava's lead generation for other
companies or other products you can't
try - you'd like tweak your marketing
tactics to increase conversion rates
before you can either remove features
from the free version add features to
summit I'm just curious what your
thoughts are yeah so so question coming
from Strava member who's a currently
free member is what are we doing about
that business model how do we how do we
think about either either evolving our
revenue sources or how do we continue to
improve the subscription business it is
a topic that is near and dear it's
constant inside Strama
I will start by the following which is
our free members are invaluable so if
you think about sort of the Strava
ecosystem and the way our system works
the fact that you're just uploading your
activity is a straw but we know is a
value because with every activity that
comes in it's it's user-generated
content and so that activity is
something that we know becomes a value
so we will remain freemium as long as
Strava exists and there will always be
an aspect of Strava that's free that
being said the second point I would make
is that we've been told for 10 years our
free is way too good our free is and it
is it's feature-rich it meets the needs
of the vast majority of our athletes
today we are aware of that and we
constantly do look at the things that
are on both sides of the paywall
if there are things that are commodity
that are on the paid side why let's move
them over to free on the other hand if
there are unique aspects of Strava that
we currently offer on free that you
can't find anywhere else we have to ask
ourselves a question why are we doing
that maybe that's something that should
actually be something that you pay for
because it's something you can only find
inside straw so we're dedicated as I
mentioned earlier to the subscription
business we really like just having that
one-to-one relationship with you as an
athlete and the onus is on
I would expect you to remain free until
we reach a point where you're looking is
saying it's a no-brainer I've got to
actually pay and by the way we're
talking about like five dollars a month
so we're not asking you to pay a lot but
it's up to us to ultimately prove to you
that the value is there on the other
side of the pay wall in the back yeah so
you were first starting with the company
like this that's very nice these users
are the exact people you want to talk to
so how much did you let their feedback
guide your vision versus what you
originally thought you wanted to make
yeah it's a it's a great question so the
question is based on this sort of
initial grassroots efforts and really
having this deep conversation with these
these passionate cyclists how much of it
was the cycle is telling us what they
wanted that we were building versus we
were actually creating something that
was new and my answer is probably I can
be very satisfactory but I would say
that there's this is the art and the
magic of any kind of product effort and
I think we got somewhat lucky at Straub
I'm going to give credit where it's due
there's a gentleman named Davie Kitchell
who's been with us from day one we call
him the mad scientist and the art is our
ability to listen hear what their needs
are but not actually build exactly what
they're asking rather think of creative
ways in which we can bring something
that's that special inside stralla so
the perfect example we were hearing
people talk about climbs and what they
were saying was that they wanted to
understand how they could measure their
performance on a climb when they were
out there it would have been easy for us
to just simply carve off that climb
based on basically grade and distance
and show them that data but when we took
a look at it we thought okay there's
some more fun things we can do here for
instance there's international standards
around how you you measure the
difficulty of a climb so let's let's
apply that international standards so
that somebody knows how hard that climb
is and then when we got really excited
was we quickly realized hey I'll bet we
can show how that person's doing against
all their buddies on that same climb I
mentioned the leaderboards a second ago
that was something nobody was telling us
about but once we added that it was game
over I mean all of a sudden
we had all these cyclists trying to
invite their friends on because they
wanted to see how they compared so it
was
it's that art of absolutely listening
and seeing what was important to them
and then what was the magic we could
bring to that was something we hadn't
necessarily heard does that make sense
and in the case of the social media
aspect of strawberry I know a number of
years ago had some bad press because
people were using it a long way and
somebody got hurt portion other
situations like that work it's kind of
like Facebook where you change the
situation yeah so question from another
strong member who's familiar with our
history and we've had we've had the
particular situation this gentleman is
bringing up is there was a time early in
our history actually this goes back to I
think our first two years there was a
Strava member who was descending a hill
actually in the Berkeley foothills was
going in at excessive speed way over the
speed limit he crossed over the double
yellow line was hit by an SUV and he
died and we unfortunately folks if
you're involved at all in cycling you'll
hear those stories weekly here even just
in the Bay Area it's it's not a safe
environment out there for cyclists yet
we're working on it but it's not great
in this particular case we were sued by
the family of the gentleman who died for
wrongful death and I think to answer
your question there were two things this
one we fought that variously it was
thrown out of the courts we were accused
of being a race director there were
there's some interesting things about
that case that we felt were patently
false and and we defended ourselves at
the same time I think your other
question was what have we done inside
the app when situations like this or I
alluded to some of the privacy things
where our heat map
we were accused of at one point in the
press of outing military bases
throughout the world because you can
look at our heat map and if you if you
basically zoom in on elements of our
heat map is basically our global
database of all activities visually
presented via heat you know via sort of
lighting for all public activities
inside Strava it's a really valuable
resource that's out there and if you go
in now you can see interesting parts of
the world and so there are folks who are
going in and they were finding places in
Afghanistan and others where there were
soldiers who were basically doing their
workouts on military bases and so we
were accused of of outing these these
bases so now here the reality of the
situation the military was very much
aware that this stuff was there they
weren't concerned with it when there
have been concerns we've worked with
governmental agencies to make sure that
we're not disclosing information that
shouldn't but I think the answer
question what we've done is we spent a
lot of time I'll give you two examples
in the case of the person who was going
downhill we look hard at sort of the way
in which people were using Strava to
think about being competitive so as an
example we don't set up leaderboards on
downhill segments it's just gone it's
not something that you can do you can do
it on up hill you can do it on flat but
we don't have those in the case of
privacy we've spent an enormity of the
thought leaders when it comes to sort of
giving our athletes total control over
the privacy of their experience you can
go completely dark on Strava
you can be single-player mode totally
private use it as your personal training
log no one will ever see anything other
than you and then you need to decide
sort of at what level you want to sort
of open it up the funny thing is we get
questions all the time we had one come
in just a few weeks ago where the
gentleman was like look it's really
important for you to be private but I'm
not on the leaderboard how come I'm not
showing up and saying we had to have the
conversations like at some point it has
to be one or the other you actually
can't we can't give you both you can't
be on leaderboards and be private so
it's a constant conversation with our
community that I think has has served us
well to figure out how to find that
balance given the request you get from
all your users that are what is the top
here No
based on the most common request yes so
the question is based on sort of all the
requests are coming in from from our
users today what would be the top of the
know list I'll give you a simple example
that pops in mind just because no we
were talking about it just last week
ironically even just with the 34 sports
that we have today
there's always both another sport that
someone wants us to add and they want us
to go deeper the irony at Strava is we
went really deep with cycling and
running and swimming as good and so
forth but there's what I call the
longtail I had some I had a gentleman
who's America's Cup sale or Olympic you
know silver medalist and so forth and
he's been pinging me by email because he
really wants us to make him proven so
that the sailing experience on Strava is
more authentic
we cannot justify that right now I mean
I love this guy to death
I want to make Strava as good a sailing
app as we possibly can but there is no
way that we can justify taking product
resources and engineering to go deep in
a sport like that not right now so that
would be an example yeah yeah yeah I
don't know if this gentleman's earlier
question I'm just curious
you talked a little bit about privacy
and how that's changed the way users
experience are you see more are you
seeing a change in the way people engage
yeah so the question was just based on
sort of all the stuff that's happening
with privacy and so forth what is Java
done if we built out as trust and safety
team are we seeing sort of changes in
the way that that our own members sort
of utilize their privacy more
effectively so quick answer yes we have
a full trust in privacy or trust and
safety team that's out of our Denver
office that's all they do it's all about
integrity trust privacy we've got a
legal team that's on that as well that
is there's one person who's dedicated
and just constant communication with our
athletes gdpr
which is the european privacy you know
obviously we were on top of that we're
trying to get ahead of it after you go
look there's some great stuff that's in
publicize recently on astrologists we
high marks in terms of frankly
simplifying privacy a lot of the privacy
stuff lot of companies have done great
work it's just it's arcane it's very
hard to to maneuver through as a user so
we took a bunch of time just to simplify
that process make it you know
point-and-click and and give our
athletes options I think that the the
theory for us is give them the option
and make sure they understand where it's
available and then put it in their hands
and that's work well for us yeah to hear
about how you approached defensibility
of your software in particular yeah
interesting question one that I hadn't
even thought about but it's it's a huge
part of Strava so the question is in
terms of sort of defense ability of our
position and and in particular the way
in which Hardware plays a role and have
we considered sort of hardware as part
of our solution or how we work with the
hardware so the short answer is we've
been very methodical and very direct in
our strategy which is to be Switzerland
what we realized early on from the very
earliest days you had you've use a
Garmin device to even upload Ostrava and
once we develop that partnership and it
actually became one where we weren't
getting what I call bloody knuckles
knocking on the door trying to get them
to just even take a meeting the reality
was it's been it's been great and so if
you fast forward to today there is not a
major hardware manufacturer in the
fitness wearable space that doesn't
integrate with Strava whether that's
Apple watch or Garmin or sinto or you
name it and we found that that's been
important we've been Switzerland we have
taken the position we will not get into
the hardware business our argument is
there's a reason they call it hardware
it's really hard to do we like the
software business and frankly we want to
give again back to athlete's choice we
find that athletes have different use
cases they have different ways in which
they want to capture their sport we
don't want to be sort of dictating how
they should do it we just want to make
sure we can work with whatever that is
that they want to do so that's service
really well and put us in a place where
we're kind of a platform so we've done
that and the other thing that we've done
is we hope
our API number of years ago I think
we're now at 40,000 API partners and so
we're just in this position where it's
rather than sort of look at this as
everybody's a foe we took the position
of everybody's a friend how can we go
and create these experiences together
and that seems to have actually
positioned us and sort of uniquely in
the marketplace how about we over here
[Music]
you stone me with the last question I
think the wrong person so the question
was how many how many free users get
supported by a single subscriber well
let me answer in a in a funny way we're
not yet profitable so you know ten years
in we're still dependent on what we're
doing so I'm not sure that we've figured
out that answer it's a mission that
we're on right now as we move towards
breakeven the business is good but
ironically we don't think it we don't we
don't think about it that way so I'd
actually have to go back and kind of run
my math to actually even be able to give
you a good answer it's what we do know
we benchmark against other freemium
businesses there's lots of subscription
businesses that are out there the
Netflix of the world and the HBO's and
so forth but there's actually not a lot
of really great freemium businesses so
we tend to benchmark against the Spotify
DH and others where there's a clear free
and then there's a paid side and we just
look at what is their percentage of
total mal or monthly active users that
are subscribing and we've been very
comfortable for the last eight years our
subscriber rate as a percentage of total
monthly active user is right where it
should have been now it's not high
enough for us personally we believe that
we can aggressively move that and that's
something we're focused on in the coming
year but that's that's the metric that
we've used is what is the percentage of
total monthly actives that are currently
subscribers
you